genc stößt derzeit in politik wirtschaft
und allgemeine öffentlichkeit auf
breites interesse insbesondere setzen
viele firmen aber auch privatpersonen
große hoffnung in den bereich des
maschinellen lernens und gehen davon aus
dass sich beispielsweise die
wirtschaftliche produktivität steigern
lässt aber auch dass das leben
möglicherweise noch bequemer wird
andererseits verbinden menschen auch
viele ängste mit dem thema künstliche
intelligenz autonome künstliche
künstlich intelligente systeme könnten
das könnten die menschen auf gewisse art
und machten entsprechen plädiere ich
dafür verstärkt den fokus nicht auf
autonome intelligente systeme sondern
auch sogenannte companions systeme zu
richten künstliche intelligenz als
partner für den menschen
mensch und maschine interaktion lösen
komplexe probleme gemeinsam die
entscheidung bleibt bei menschen das
system hilft den menschen die
komplexität zu meistern
entsprechend möchte ich ihnen in einem
vortrag größere einblicke tiefere
einblicke in den bereich der kann als
partner kognitiv enhancement stadt
digitale verdunkelt